heute was sitzt offenbar um und ruft die
ganz sita hahaha
ein uhu mit dem spruch
gehört aber die fans die gewitzten thema
hübsch egal - sie sind überhaupt lachen
film ist aber gern lachen hilft ist
menschlich wenige momente stress bei
angst aber ein paar situationen humor
ist glaube ich so etwas wie eine
abwehrreaktion schafft distanz zu der
welt aber zugesagt wie das genau
funktioniert und warum er überhaupt bis
komisch verhindert dass irgendeine sache
genauer in der philosophie geht es grob
zeit drei wichtige theorien darüber
warum er überhaupt lustig oder komisch
findet die erste und älteste theorie ist
theorie für die überlegenheit
der platon und sport der englische
philosoph thomas hobbes und klein
ursachen lacher ist es plötzlich gefühl
von überlegenheit
stoff oder bananenschalen 100 dort
durchs gesicht meldungen zur france
gesagt wie andere schützt vor allem aber
schlimme ist nicht wirklich also lasst
uns ehrlich so zeigen will mehr saubere
nicht betroffen sind die überlegenheit
theorie slapstick aber aus satire
ziemlich gut klar aber auch viel witz
zum beispiel sogenannte ostfriesenwitze
beispiel warum stellt ostfriese immer
zwei gläser wasser aufs nachtisch events
körper schlafes fonds glas und dass lars
klaus antwort sie wisse noch nicht ob
sie dann auch durch stein- oder nicht er
findet das lustig wenn man seinen
krippen ich schon so blöd sie gefühle
dies also überlagert es gibt aber der
film es wurde die theorie schlachtfeld
vorher zum beispiel was macht ein clown
im büro
antwortfax
davids basiert nicht auf überlegenheit
sondern auch von anderen prinzip nämlich
auf dem kongress womit man bittet zweite
theorie wert
im 17 jahrhundert also grob zeit mit der
aufklärung werden neue humor theorie
domina die sogenannte inkongruenz
theorie und die seit komik entstehen
wenn zwei sachen wo überhaupt nicht
zusammenpassen ein zum beispiel
minderjährige tochter der heime in die
großen schuhe oder gar nicht läuft und
zur tour das war aus nummer oder zum
beispiel woody allen sei klar wie zwar
nicht alles aber nach dem tod zur
sicherheit name aber immer 22 euro und
damit der immanuel kant überwiegend so
lange vor der inkongruenz theorie
verzerrt ein witz formular wo sich
angeblich so festgeld er sogar die
berühmte lauberhorn geholt unmöglich
aber genau darum witzig den kranz der
imam nicht mehr lachen viel sachverstand
für einen kurzen moment dass ich ein
kranz rund um den mieter weiß ist es
dank wird zeigt auf dem falschen fuß
erwischt wie zum beispiel dem wirzweli
hoher fall wenn die alten römer kam
antwort wir sind als sie
sobald man aber jetzt verstört märkten
sind auf dem falschen dampfer sie die
geistige anspannung löste und dass gott
das ventil und minister aus spanien
weglachen womit mir bitte dritte theorie
wert
der wichtigste vertreter von der theorie
ist der österreichische autor sigmund
freud für der freud dieses lachen immer
ein ventil funktion überschüssige
energie wird abgleicht wieder freizeit
viele wie zum beispiel brecher das
tappen und zeigt jetzt auch warum
eigentlich netze die sagen sie sind fies
erwarten passieren doch stereotyp sind
sexistisch oder fremdenfeindlich dank
mal wieder blondinenwitz oder
abschätzige witze über andere aktionen
an der kultur für die freude ist klar
die grund wurde umgebracht hat ist dass
man eigentlich nicht darf die darüber
wachen der aufwand vor der innere zensur
seite freut wird sie die glocken und
unterdrückt die für knigge gedanken und
gefühle zum vorschein münze also wird
ein nicht mühsam unterdrücken sondern
könnt die ganze energie einfach weg
lacht lache heißt also energie sportlich
ist das high mix energiemix energie
eingespart umriss noch freut aber ohne
könig fühlen wie zum beispiel
peinlichkeit fremdscham ärger oder
mitleid er lacht über bis in werk und
nahmen es nicht so wichtig und das ist
letztlich war es schön am humor das ist
einfach schafft sache zu relativieren
sie von anderer seite netzwerke mit
distanz mit leichtigkeit ohne db die
tragische moment vom laufen ganz zu ende
letztlich ist leider immer beides
komödie und tragödie und humor da hilft
es da wie das blog und verstehe ich
überhaupt widerspruch besser bezahlte
humorig wie man so schön sein wenn man
trotzdem lacht so zumindest nicht das
aber wie stellt er zum thema humor was
bedeutet humor das land verraten was ist
ihre lieblingsfarbe die kommentare
[Musik]